it was a big night for the musical trio
chapel heart on this latest episode of
america's scottish you know our director
ryan doesn't let me sing in here i'm not
allowed to sing let it go because you
sing frozen every day
every day i don't like my singing but i
respect it right i know where my place
is
the true corrupt and small town of
mississippi perform their original dolly
parton inspires song you can have me
jolene which they originally released
back in march of 2021 however they saw
their dreams come true one step closer
to reality immediately winning the
hearts of the audiences and all four
judgments that's right despite each of
the judges and host terry crews having
already given out their golden buzzers
they broke all the rules and did
something very special to honor chapel
hearts incredible performance take a
look and we'll see you next time bye
we were so inspired by this
we just love the storyline and we
figured though from 1973 to 2022 we
could not still be fighting over the
same man
we decided to tell her you could just
have him jolene
i like that i love time he's your
problem
well i've tried so much to reverse
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh my god
trust me
i needed you today
i mean
that was fantastic amazing i love you
we've been trying to break into
nashville for the last couple years but
it's been kind of hard when i think
country music doesn't always look like
us i love the song i love the energy i
love the look you say country music
doesn't look like you that is your win
because you are going to be the original
if i hadn't used my golden buzzer i
would give you a golden
[Applause]
me
buzzer
i have an idea
[Applause]
five four three two one
here
[Applause]